Mō tātou, a, mō ka uri a muri ake nei
Over the last couple of months, we’ve reached
some tremendous Regeneration milestones.
In June, the Minister for Greater Christchurch
Regeneration, the Honourable Megan Woods,
held an official ceremony for the handover
of Regeneration land into Council ownership.
This is about land going back to local ownership
with communities being fully in power of the
future of what happens in their community
and I think that is something that everyone
in Canterbury will celebrate.
And $18.6 million dollars in funding over
the next 10 years has been approved for the
Regeneration by the Council in the recent
Long Term Plan
It’s excellent, it means the next 2-3 years
of projects are now firmly set in concrete.
Finishing the Wharf here, and then moving
into the playing fields, and bmx track and
dog park.
Because up to now, a lot of it has been underground
and not very visible, we’re moving into
the very visible and exciting parts now.
The reconstruction of Courtenay Drive has
now been completed, and we really appreciate
the patience of nearby residents as this work
was carried out and we dealt with the discovery
of asbestos underneath the road surface.
If you’ve been in the area over the last
few months, you will have noticed the cranes
working away behind me.
Today we’re going get to get an update on
progress in the Kaiapoi Marine Precinct
This is a large project which involves the
installation of a new river wall, the driving
of new piles, and the complete reconstruction
of the stop bank.
Lowering down the stopbank, is for Daniel
Smith to come back in and install the tie-backs,
for the sheet-pile wall, which is pulling
on the tension for the new riverwall which
is going in.
Once that’s done, ECAN will come back to
reinstate the stop banks and once that’s
done, the builders for the terrace will come
back in and start building the terraces.
It is hoped that the terraces will be completed
towards the end of this year, along with the
neighbouring private development.
Installation of the floating pontoons will
require dredging of the river.
Resource consent for that work has just been
consented, and it’s expected to take place
over winter as part of a wider dredging programme.
A new draft Kaiapoi Town Centre plan will
soon be out for public consultation.
This document plans for the future of Kaiapoi’s
Town Centre and the adjacent Mixed-Use Business
Areas.
Make sure you take a look at the plan and
submit your feedback when it’s released
in August.
In the next update, we’ll look at the soon-to-be
completed road link here in the Kaiapoi East
Regeneration Area which will be known as Feldwick
Drive, and we’ll talk about the upcoming
masterplan for this area including projects
like the dog park and bmx track.